[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález la oposición de
centroderecha en argentina consiguió
imponerse en las elecciones
parlamentarias de este fin de semana
unos comicios que buscaban la renovación
de una buena parte del congreso de ese
país suramericano
así es como quedaron las cosas a grandes
rasgos para la renovación de la mitad de
la cámara de diputados la coalición
opositora conocida como juntos por el
cambio quedó nueve puntos por encima del
oficialismo conocido como frente de
todos mientras que en el senado en el
que debía renovarse un tercio de los
senadores el frente de todos sufrió una
derrota electoral aún mayor al quedar 20
puntos por debajo de la oposición una
derrota histórica para el peronismo en
argentina en el senado para
particularmente que perdió así la
mayoría en la cámara alta por primera
vez en tres décadas se los ponemos en
palabras más simples en el siguiente
reportaje veamos
la oposición gana terreno en argentina
tras 38 años del regreso de la
democracia a las fuerzas políticas
cambian en el congreso-
millones de argentinos en todo el país
dijeron basta dijeron basta
el gobierno peronista de centroizquierda
pasará a tener 35 de los 72 escaños los
fernández tendrán que buscar coaliciones
al no tener el control del congreso voy
a dirigirme a los representantes de la
voluntad popular y a las fuerzas
políticas a las que representan para
acordar una agenda tan compartida como
sea posible
una oposición responsable y abierta el
diálogo es una oposición patriótica
nuestro pueblo necesita de ese
patriotismo el gobierno enfrenta una
dura crisis económica con una inflación
anual de más del 40 por ciento una
pobreza que afecta al 40 por ciento de
la población y el desempleo que ronda el
10 por ciento además argentina debe
renegociar con el fondo monetario
internacional un acuerdo con el que el
gobierno anterior obtuvo 44 mil millones
de dólares en financiación la fuerza del
ex presidente mauricio macri gana
asientos en el senado pero tampoco
tendrá la mayoría en las calles los
argentinos dicen que la respuesta de las
urnas es una clara señal de cambio por
un lado alivio
por el otro miedo la realidad paralela
que vive el gobierno nacional
porque estamos empezando la derrota a
pesar de la prevista derrota en las
urnas fernández mantiene el control de
la cámara de diputados lo que deja con
vida al peronismo
que viene ahora para los dos años que
restan del gobierno del presidente
alberto fernández que temas de peso
tiene la agenda del gobierno en materia
económica sanitaria y política en donde
está presente este nuevo congreso que va
a jugar un papel fundamental que
elecciones también debe aprender el
peronismo con estas elecciones
parlamentarias que lectura hacen del
sentido de la sociedad argentina y debe
la oposición acortar distancia con el
gobierno para sumar el hombro y ayudar a
resolver las verdaderas necesidades del
país más allá de mantener las
diferencias políticas las elecciones en
argentina un castigo para el peronismo
es nuestro tema para el debate de france
24 y para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a mara brawer ella es diputada
nacional por el partido por la coalición
al frente de todos ella está en la
ciudad de buenos aires en la capital
argentina también está con nosotros se
une a esta conversación ricardo baile ls
diputado nacional por el partido unión
cívica radical y en el estudio de france
24 nos acompaña matías franzini él es
profesor de la facultad de estudios
internacionales
y políticos y urbanos de la universidad
del rosario en la ciudad de bogotá en
colombia él es doctor en relaciones
internacionales ustedes también nuestros
televidentes pueden participar en el
debate con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como france24 guión bajo s
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo nuestra etiqueta
es numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas
comienzo en la ciudad de buenos aires
con mara brawer mara gracias por estar
con nosotros bienvenida al programa y
comienzo partiendo de la pregunta básica
su opinión el balance que usted hace de
estos comicios parlamentarios de medio
término en argentina
es un gusto compartir con ustedes con
estas fueron unas elecciones como ha
sucedido en muchos países del mundo
donde los oficialismo hemos tenido
problemas para
hacer buenas elecciones en el sentido de
que fuimos los más castigados producto
de las complejas medidas no sólo en
argentina sino en el mundo se tuvieron
que tomar producto la pandemia no elegir
entre el trabajo y la salud fueron
decisiones
que hicieron que era necesario pero
muchos argentinos como muchas personas a
lo largo del continente vivieron épocas
muy difíciles vivimos todos épocas muy
difíciles nosotros hicimos una lección a
las paso mejoramos mucho en esta
elección definitiva no sólo tenemos un
sistema cómo sería de primera vuelta de
segunda vuelta para los países para
aquellos que no conocen el sistema hemos
mejorado mucho mantenemos la primera
minoría en la cámara de diputados
mantenemos la primera minoría en el
senado
eso significa que somos el bloque de mal
los sistemas senadores tenemos y por
supuesto nosotros hicimos muchísimas
promesas y proyectos de vida para los
argentinos cuando ganamos las elecciones
en el 2019 producto la pandemia
muchísimas cosas no pudimos cumplir
también producto algunos errores como
tiene cualquier cualquier gobierno y
bueno habiendo vacunado a casi toda la
población argentina ya con una clara
indicadores de la economía resurgiendo
ya tenemos índices mayores que los que
tenían el gobierno anterior por ejemplo
en actividad fabril soy padre pensamos
que no como dijeron ustedes que por
tener el perdón o no ustedes el informe
decía que el peronismo sigue vivo el
peronismo sigue vivo desde el año 45
este no es la primera vez que no va mal
en una elección y lo importante es
entender mensaje a la gente y el mensaje
de la gente lo que nos dijo es hicimos
mucho esfuerzo con lo que ustedes
hicieron no nos alcanzó por eso nosotros
tenemos que mejorar y hemos mejorado en
estos meses decimos este en función de
esto sacado más 2 en dobles entre las
pasos y estas elecciones
también en la ciudad de buenos aires en
ricardo buryaile le pregunto también
cuál es su balance de estos comicios
parlamentarios
buenas noches buenas noches
ahora que cuesta mucho entender al
oficialismo cuando presenta esta derrota
como un triunfo
de hecho el día pasado mañana creo que
va a haber una movilización para
festejar el triunfo de las elecciones
que planteaba y lo planteó el presidente
la república y también lo planteó uno de
los candidatos a diputados nacionales
por el frente de todos en la ciudad
autónoma la elección más exitosa del
kirchnerismo
creo que el oficialismo no ha tenido una
lectura clara de lo que le ha dicho la
gente la gente le ha dicho que manejar
muy mal la economía que manejaron muy
mal la pandemia no solamente fue la
pandemia sino que fueron otras
cuestiones de incumplimientos de trato
con la pandemia
del mal manejo de la justicia de la
liberación de precios de una política
internacional donde no reconoce la
violación de los derechos humanos en
venezuela no reconoce la violación de
derechos humanos en cuba en nicaragua
entonces centrarnos en la pandemia para
decir que el gobierno ha tenido una dura
derrota es minimizar lo que ha expresado
el pueblo argentino por argentino por
por casi 9 puntos le ha dicho al
oficialismo que no ha hecho las cosas
bien y que esperemos que el rumbo se
rectifique que no es cierto que la
economía está mejor que antes hoy la
argentina rondas más del 40 por ciento
de pobreza más del 10 por ciento de
desocupación la actividad económica
tiene un crecimiento por supuesto
tomando como base un muy mal año como ha
sido el año 2020 con una caída de 10
puntos del producto bruto sí pero el
déficit está el argentino no se
soluciona por lo tanto la inflación hoy
supera el 52 por ciento ya que el
estudio de france 24 para terminar esta
ronda a matías su opinión el balance que
usted hace de estos comicios y bueno si
santiago buenas noches el diputado y la
diputada bueno primero digamos me mi
lectura como analistas si es de una
derrota del oficialismo en estas
elecciones
si uno compara digamos los números de
2019 cuando alberto llega a la
presidencia hay una calle importante en
casi todas las provincias
el frente de todos se lleva en esta
elección más o menos un tercio de los
votos lo que es un piso bastante bajo
histórico para el peronismo entonces
creo que en ese sentido si hay ahí
hay un claro un claro mensaje
mucho voto bronca y voy a coincidir con
la diputada son situaciones así una
situación complicada por muchos motivos
la pandemia y otras cosas llamó
particularmente la situación económica
argentina que tampoco es nueva digamos
la cuestión de la crisis de la crisis
económica y esto tiene inicialmente una
repercusión directa que es una
repercusión institucional que es el
hecho de que el peronismo pierde su
hegemonía histórica dentro de la cámara
de senadores y pierde el quórum propio y
juntos por el cambio equilibra la
situación dentro de la cámara diputados
cierto entonces esto como reflejo
institucional de esta votación el punto
es que como suele pasar en las
democracias que tienen este elecciones
de medio término como pasan los eeuu por
ejemplo esto también es una lectura para
el futuro de la democracia argentina
para el futuro del gobierno y para las
posibilidades de tanto la coalición
gobernante o diferente frente de todos o
digamos las perspectivas de juntos para
el cambio y creo que la lectura general
o por lo menos la lectura que uno hace
es que en esta carrera
recién empieza que va a ser una carrera
dura son dos años creo que argentina
antes de dos años difícil por delante
juntos por el cambio parte desde una
posición más beneficiosa digamos pero en
fin uno leyendo o analizando la política
argentina siempre siempre sabe que es
muy difícil hacer pronósticos y es una
situación muy difícil de leer pero
justamente le iba a preguntar matías por
los pronósticos por el futuro por estos
dos años que le restan al presidente
fernández al frente de argentina cuáles
serán o deben ser esos temas prioridad
en la agenda que tiene que sacar el
presidente adelante teniendo en cuenta
la nueva conformación que tiene ahora el
congreso ya hablaremos más adelante como
puede ser esa negociación pero cuál
puede ser la agenda desde su punto de
vista bueno creo que la agenda es
fundamentalmente económica cierto que es
histórico en argentina
de nuevo esta crisis que argentina está
viviendo inflación difícil digamos
problemas de la deuda pública bajo nivel
de inversión bajo nivel de crecimiento
yo suelo decir que argentina está en una
economía pandémicas antes de la pandemia
es cierto esta situación no es nueva
y este es el principal punto que
argentina tiene que resolver y el
gobierno de alberto fernández tiene que
resolver en los próximos dos años y creo
que va a ser el principal elemento el
principal eje de éxito o de fracaso de
lo que le resta de mandato y creo que
esto está reconocido por la mayor parte
de las de las fuerzas políticas
de hecho digamos una de las el proceso
de
digamos asimilación que hizo el gobierno
de la derrota en las primarias cierto en
septiembre fue justamente esto
necesitamos más recursos económicos en
la calle transición de que el fracaso
que fue un fracaso mayor en las
primarias de lo que creo que terminó
siendo ahora tenía que ver con esa
situación entonces la agenda
fundamentalmente es económica con varios
varios frentes pero la cuestión más
urgente y la cuestión fundamental tiene
que ver con la deuda pública la
negociación con el fondo eso es inédita
le hago la misma pregunta amar a la
ciudad de buenos aires- la agenda
prioritaria del presidente
ese margen de negociación que pueda
tener con la coalición él mismo ha dicho
que tiene la necesidad de negociar con
la coalición que es una nueva etapa que
es hay una necesidad en argentina de que
se construya una unidad son palabras del
presidente fernández si tiene margen de
negociación y cuál puede ser la la
agenda prioritaria aquí en matías decía
el tema económico
no por supuesto como dijo el presidente
nosotros tenemos que ponernos de acuerdo
con la oposición eso fortalece a la
democracia en lo que tiene que ver con
la deuda por el fondo monetario
internacional ustedes saben que el
gobierno anterior esté violando los
estatutos del fondo recibió una deuda de
45 mil millones de dólares que se
fugaron este a través de lo que es la
fuga de capitales lo acaba de confesar
el ex presidente macri que se lo dio a
bancos es decir ustedes saben que el
fondo monetario no paga no da no da
créditos para la experiencia
esterilización de los capitales sino
para inversión bueno esa plata
desapareció argentina se fugó y ahora
tenemos una enorme deuda eso por
supuesto es el pasado y lo tenemos que
tener presente para que no se vuelva a
repetir no el fondo monetario no puede
violar sus normas ni argentinas puede
pedir este endeudar por 100 años a los
argentinos
para jugar capitales pero ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es ponernos de acuerdo
para para abordar entre todos aquello
que el gobierno va a proponer como pago
de la deuda al fondo monetario y después
por supuesto lo decía bien el
comentarista recién nosotros no
decidimos antes de la pandemia
un país en pandemia de hecho antes de la
pandemia en el mes de diciembre nosotros
en el congreso declaramos la emergencia
económica social financiera y sanitaria
antes de la pandemia después vino la
pandemia los indicadores que decía
recién ricardo de este 50 por ciento
inflación 10 casi 10 puntos los empleos
son los indicadores que dejaron ellos en
su gobierno entonces
a partir de ahora estamos mejorando yo
jamás que les voy a comparar un dato
económico en la argentina lo voy a
comparar con el año 2020 no sería
honesto ni parte siempre que comparó
comparo con el 19 si no es muy fácil
decir que mejoramos nosotros estamos
mejorando con respecto al 19 al último
mes del gobierno de macri sin pandemia
riccardo su opinión sobre estas
posibilidades de negociación entre las
coaliciones para poder hacer un frente
completo para negociar con el fondo
monetario internacional porque el tema
económico le concierne a todos
en primer lugar creo que la coalición
tiene que ponerse de acuerdo entre ellos
han sido muy duros con el presidente de
la republica miembros integrantes de la
cual están la propia vicepresidenta ha
hecho una carta muy dura descalificando
al presidente ya muchos de sus ministros
después de una elección como ha sido la
primera vuelta algunos colegas de la
cámara de diputados lo han tratado muy
mal al presidente entonces uno el primer
punto que dice es con quién estoy
hablando quién tiene el poder en la
argentina la realidad es que nosotros no
sabemos si el poder lo tiene el
presidente o la vicepresidente por más
que todos asumimos que el poder lo tiene
la vicepresidenta por lo tanto uno se
sienta a negociar y quiere pensar que
está negociando con quien tienen el
poder que es el presidente quién va a
convocar en segundo lugar es muy difícil
asomar una negociación cuando la culpa
es solamente de del gobierno anterior
desconociendo para la realidad de la
economía el problema del
el problema de la economía argentina no
es la deuda es que el déficit y el
malgasto público que tiene la argentina
hace muchísimos años por lo tanto pensar
que el problema es solamente la deuda la
deuda es la exteriorización del problema
es argentina un estado se financia con
emisión monetaria o con endeudamiento
por ejemplo o con suba de impuestos este
es un gobierno que ha decidido subir
impuestos emitir dinero y congelar
tarifas creo que el primer punto para
sentarnos a hablar es que el propio
gobierno se sienten se sienten hablar
entre ellos para saber qué quieren
proponer y segundo punto hablan de
entablar un diálogo es muy difícil
entablar un diálogo con quien no ha
reconocido una derrota de hecho no han
felicito a la oposición primer punto han
terminado las elecciones y para entablar
un diálogo convocan de buenas a primeras
en una agenda que no tiene nada que ver
con lo económico sino con la violación a
la propiedad privada en muchos casos en
algunos que tienen que ver con
ocupaciones ilegales de predios que hay
en la argentina por lo tanto creo que
para avanzar en cualquier diálogo
primero se tiene que poner de acuerdo al
gobierno y después convocamos a nosotros
riccardo sigo con ustedes allí conectada
a la ciudad de buenos aires muchos
analistas tienen una pregunta común y es
con esta necesidad que tiene argentina
de sacar adelante la economía
que giro puede tener entonces el
gobierno es mantenerse siendo más rígido
mucho más ortodoxo o mantener un poco
unas políticas un poco más socialistas
más de izquierda cuál es la salida que
puede tener este país para sacar
adelante la economía
a mí si usted me pregunta cuál es la
salida para la argentina en inversión
privada es un sinceramiento del tipo de
cambio argentina hoy tiene un atraso del
tipo de cambio en la necesidad de
generar una justicia confiable y por
supuesto tocar lo que son las leyes
laborales en la argentina que nos han
descolocado del mundo en la presión
impositiva en la argentina está diez
puntos por encima de la media de los
países de latinoamérica y solamente
cuatro puntos por debajo de lo que es la
ocde en 18 meses se han tocado 18
impuestos en la argentina por lo tanto
yo creo que en estos casos lo que se
hace necesario es generar la confianza
para las inversiones tanto internas como
la inversión extranjera un sinceramiento
del tipo de cambio y un aggiornamiento
de las leyes laborales impositivas y
monetarias para que la argentina pueda
crecer después de más de 12 años más de
12 años que la argentina no genera
empleo privado y empleo privado de
calidad por lo tanto creo que ese es el
giro que debe tener nuestro país para su
opinión al respecto sobre cuál giro en
términos económicos debe dar el país
bueno estoy de acuerdo que la inversión
privada es fundamental de hecho
comparado con el anterior semestre el
mismo semestre del año 2009 19 han
aumentado las inversiones privadas en un
13% y han habido de inversiones de 40
empresas por un monto de 13 mil millones
de dólares entonces las inversiones
privadas ésta también tiene que haber un
estado presente y yo discuto lo que dice
diputado buryaile en relación al aumento
de los impuestos acá el único que le
aumentó impuestos al pueblo es el jefe
gobierno la ciudad rodríguez la recta
que aumentó 1 por ciento los gastos de
las tarjetas de crédito y si estás que
un argentino perdón un porteño limpio
vive en la ciudad buenos aires gasta con
su tarjeta de crédito le tiene que pagar
el 1 por ciento al gobernador de la
ciudad buenos aires impuestos que lo
puso en plena pandemia después
y los servicios públicos tienen sus
tarifas congeladas y lo único que
aumentaron argentina es el impuesto a
las grandes fortunas que es justamente
lo que defiende el sector político del
diputado buryaile nosotros creemos y
tenemos una enorme deuda sería mentirosa
decir que lo hemos logrado
modificar nuestro régimen tributario
para que sea progresivo tenemos una
enorme dificultad con esto pero también
una enorme dificultad con la oposición
que cuando quisimos este poner un aporte
extraordinario en plena pandemia para
las grandes fortunas de argentina me
refiero al 0,02 por ciento de los
argentinos la oposición puso el grito en
el 7 entonces hay que apostar al
desarrollo científico-tecnológico
por suerte volvimos a tener ministerio
de ciencia y tecnología porque el
gobierno anterior lo había cerrado
esto se ha demostrado el avance
científico tecnológico argentina con los
enormes cantidad de tests por ejemplo
para detectar el coronavirus que hemos
tenido ya tenemos en fase 2 una vacuna
suele apostar a des primarizar nuestra
economía sumándole va a haber valor
agregado a nuestros productos generar
más y mejores puestos de trabajo y
siempre con impuestos progresivos
sigo con usted para hacerle una pregunta
rápida sobre unas de las declaraciones
que dio el ex presidente mauricio macri
tan pronto se dieron a conocer los
resultados de estas elecciones y el ex
presidente macri dijo que se venían dos
años de transición para argentina que
cree usted a qué se refería el ex
presidente macri con ese término
el presidente de macri siempre anda
bordeando lo antidemocrático no una vez
dijo que el presidente había que tirarlo
por un tren éste
estaba a los jueces por la televisión
los citaba jugar al tenis con él y
significa un gobierno de transición un
gobierno que el pueblo lo votó por
cuatro años así en nuestro mandato
constitucional este y seguiremos
gobernando los cuatro años y le pedimos
a la oposición que dialogue el
presidente convoca al diálogo obviamente
luego el diálogo en donde se efectiviza
en el congreso en el congreso somos los
diputados diputadas y senadores los que
nos tenemos que poner de acuerdo no hay
democracia en el mundo que se pueda
sustentar de manera óptima si no hay una
oposición que quiera dialogar entonces
en vez de interpretar lo que si nosotros
nos llevamos bien nos llevamos mal se
podría contar miles de cosas de la
oposición que se llama pero me parece
que bajaría el nivel de este debate no
ser este nosotros tuvimos una lección
muy mala en las pasos mejoramos en estas
elecciones no es la primera vez que un
gobierno en el medio término no le va
tan mal christina en el 2009 hizo una
pésima elección y dos años después ganó
por ganó con el 54% tenemos que mejorar
terminó la pandemia los argentinos están
vacunados y queremos gobernar el diálogo
democrático con la oposición bueno
quiero avanzar con otros temas
relacionados con esas elecciones del
domingo matías y es el papel que
tuvieron que tuvo el partido de la
izquierda que se convierte entonces en
la tercera fuerza política digamos lo
hace a nivel nacional destacado balance
de este partido de su desempeño en estas
elecciones bueno más que balance sobre
la izquierda me gustaría por ahí hacer
un balance más general en relación
algunos cambios que han pasado en el
escenario argentino términos electorales
y en términos de partidos políticos en
los últimos años uno tiene que ver con
el hecho de que digamos este voto bronca
que se proyectó tanto en las primarias
como en esta última elección se canalizó
fundamentalmente a través de juntos por
el cambio cierto y esto es una es un
elemento nuevo en la política argentina
en las últimas dos décadas cierto
históricamente y particularmente durante
el ciclo de néstor y cristina díaz la
oposición siempre fue muy débil y en
argentina sin embargo esa es la tercera
elección consecutiva en la cual hay un
buen porcentaje de la población que vota
en ese partido esto es digamos hay hay
un montón de digamos deliberaciones
sobre lo que significa tener partidos
digamos alternándose en el poder y lo
positivo que es para la democracia pero
esto es un dato fundamental de los
últimos tiempos en argentina y el otro
punto es que aún en este marco de alguna
forma no diría rebelión pero sí de
insatisfacción profunda con lo que está
pasando y creo que esto es algo positivo
el elector argentino no se fragmentó y
no se fue a los extremos
entonces hubo un avance de la izquierda
sí pero en términos digamos no se vuelve
una opción para la presidencia en 2023
por ejemplo un avance también de la
derecha cierto
particularmente en ciudad buenos aires
en provincia de buenos aires con miller
y con experto pero también estas son me
parece por lo menos por ahora
expresiones este
periféricas del sistema político cuando
estoy apuntando por esto y veía la
imagen de de bolt sonar recién es un
poco esta era lógica uno no ve en
argentina la emergencia de
figuras
populistas extremas autoritarias que
estén capitalizando este proceso de
insatisfacción profunda en el sistema
político creo que eso es positivo
obviamente que las fuerzas en argentina
leen estas cuestiones de forma diferente
y los dicen todos probablemente
estableciendo el proceso de forma
diferente pero de una perspectiva más
más analítica general creo que ese es un
elemento positivo de lo que dejaron las
elecciones también el hecho de que
si uno compara también lo que ha pasado
es decir lo que ha pasado en eeuu
esta era una elección donde el gobierno
sabía que iba a perder y que preveía en
algunos pero algunos dineros que podía
perder todavía peor en relación a
septiembre y sin embargo un proceso
electoral sin denuncias de fraude sin
manejar hay tranquilidad los certámenes
podrán votar con completa tranquilidad
creo que eso es un elemento positivo a
destacar de todo este proceso a dónde va
a dónde va a la izquierda y a dónde va a
la derecha es difícil de saber argentina
argentina y estoy digamos la izquierda
en argentina siempre ha tenido el límite
del peronismo porque tenemos el
peronismo ha captado digámoslo
movimiento de izquierda peronismo es un
fenómeno bastante complejo que incorpora
cuestiones más de izquierda a derecha
etcétera pero siempre le pone ese límite
en mi visión particular yo no veo por lo
menos en el corto plazo la el
crecimiento de estos extremos políticos
en argentina lo que me parece que es
positivo para para el diario democrático
y ahí coincido que tiene que haber
digamos una cierta convergencia entre
los partidos políticos mayoritarios me
quedan cinco minutos para finalizar el
programa quiero hablar de la figura
importante destacada que sigue siendo la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández cuál
es su opinión sobre
lo que sucedió en estos comicios porque
perdió el control como ya lo decíamos de
la cámara alta también hubo derrotas
destacadas e importantes para la
vicepresidenta en la provincia de
mendoza en corrientes y también en la
pampa y marginó del congreso argentino a
tres políticas que eran muy cercanas a
la vicepresidenta que lecturas y usted
de este desempeño a nivel electoral
mire yo creo que lo que en la argentina
se votaba en 8 provincias para elegir
senadores y la cámara que preside la
doctora
en seis provincias ganó la oposición una
de las cuales es la pampa no había
ganado desde el año 83 en todas las
derrotas fue abrumadora y creo que gran
parte de la responsabilidad lo tiene la
vicepresidenta y cuando dijo la
vicepresidenta es porque el proceso que
vive la argentina es un desgaste a la
autoridad presidencial y este desgaste a
la autoridad y la falta de credibilidad
en la palabra presidencial tiene su
origen en el propio presidente de la
república y en las internas del propio
partido la argentina no necesita
certidumbres y esa certidumbre no se la
da al oficialismo y creo que la actual
vicepresidenta ha llevado al presidente
que ha llevado al país a una situación
de disminución de la autoridad
presidencial
esto es muy malo para la argentina esto
no es conveniente
y por lo tanto creo que la
vicepresidenta es una de las grandes
responsables de la situación política el
propio gobierno
ahora llegamos a la recta final de este
programa quiero conocer las conclusiones
de lo que se viene en el plano inmediato
para la argentina en términos políticos
su gran conclusión de este tema
y que podamos en el congreso dialogar
democráticamente con la oposición los
resultados electorales son justamente
eso en la democracia funcionando
argentina en sus 38 años consecutivos de
democracia nunca ha tenido denuncias de
fraude electorales nosotros siempre
hemos tenido desde que recuperamos la
democracia procesos muy limpios y el
juego la democracia es esto a veces se
gana a veces se pierde se tiene más
diputados más senadores y nosotros ahora
lo que tenemos por delante es poner de
nuevo a la argentina de pie después de
la enorme situación difícil que se vivió
en la pandemia donde ustedes lo saben
bien francia ha perdido casi 10 puntos
del pbi de todos los países del mundo
han tenido graves dificultades
económicas y salimos de la pandemia
estamos vacunados y estamos fuertemente
aportando a una argentina productiva que
esa es la característica que siempre ha
tenido el peronismo no lo que se le el
empresariado nacional que es lo que
nosotros defendemos la inversión en
argentina la cuestación argentina
respetar los derechos de los
trabajadores y eso es nuestra promesa
electoral y eso es lo que tenemos por
delante esperamos que la oposición
acepte el diálogo y a mí me parece que
los que disminuyen la autoridad
presidencial que se disminuyera en la
oposición no reconociéndolo como tal
después las interpretaciones que hagan
de cómo nos llevamos en nuestra fuerza
política nuestra fuerza política es una
coalición de gobierno es una experiencia
novedosa también para para nosotros en
una etapa así tenemos
varias fuerzas políticas que hay para
sergio massa
alberto fernández nuestro presidente el
kirchnerismo cristina fernández de
kirchner somos muchas fuerzas del
peronismo tradicional que nos hemos
unido para llevar adelante este gobierno
y
me queda un minuto el programa para que
los otros invitados puedan hacer también
las conclusiones y matías rápidamente
por favor acá la conclusión bien creo
que digamos la pelota está en el aire
como para hacer una analogía
futbolística no está claro qué es lo que
va a pasar en los próximos en los
próximos meses este los próximos días
creo que van a ser importantes
particularmente en relación la propuesta
económica que vais a hacer alberto que
hasta ahora no ha sido en estos dos años
no ha quedado del todo claro creo que
ahí está ahí se juega el futuro de
argentina porque ahí se juega también la
posibilidad de que éste de que esta
propuesta sea aceptada dialogada uno
claro y riccardo su conclusión
rápidamente por favor
creo que el gobierno de un rumbo
político y económico y debe decidir en
qué parte estamos y estamos en un mundo
capitalista aceptando el afectado del
mundo capitalista os creemos que el
mundo que vive es el mundo
y en esa línea el presidente puede
decidir cuál es el rumbo que que
necesita la argentina y abrirse al mundo
a la negociación tanto política como
económica
bueno pues son horas cruciales para
argentina definir el rumbo de este país
para los próximos dos años y para lo que
resta de este gobierno del presidente
alberto fernández ahí tienen ustedes las
opiniones de nuestros invitados y el
análisis de estas elecciones
parlamentarias de medio término que
cambia por completo el panorama
parlamentario allí en argentina y van a
ser dos años muy interesantes para
analizar a nivel político y también
económico para este país suramericano
ustedes puede seguir dejando sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales y pueden seguir
escribiendo allí todo lo que quieran
consultar sobre este tipo de temas que
estamos debatiendo aquí en france24 mis
invitados muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros hoy y ustedes pues
sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]